[Music]
we're excited
I've been 11 years and it's I guess the
thing that's most exciting is that the
everybody is coming back I mean the
whole cast the whole crew the same you
know wardrobe people the same makeup
saving hair I mean it's just a testament
to how close a family we were and the
chance to sort of come back for this
little this little sprint and just to
play again especially now when there's
so much to talk about
what's happening in our in our country
we got a call a couple of weeks after we
did that nine-minute get-out-the-vote
skit which was first time the tenant
that we were together in the same room
in ten years and when we did it we could
not believe how comfortable it was and
how it felt like no time had passed and
then that that video got seven million
views and so NBC was like wow no slacker
never wish I bring them back and they
called it what do you guys think and the
four of us had dinner together and we
just looked around we were like what do
we think and ultimately we thought you
know what we need to laugh and we need
to make people laugh because this has
been a rough year and we have a lot to
say you have to vote no it is unamerican
not to but does my vote even matter I
mean how can one unemployed whitefella
registered in Pennsylvania make a
difference
it's the perfect time for our show
because it's already been established
that our show shines a light on what's
happening in culture and politics and we
we make you laugh about it but we also
make you think and it feels like it's
prime for that
[Music]